i'm here with frances haugen she is a
former facebook employee a whistleblower
who put forward a complaint against the
company with u.s law enforcement and
testified before the u.s congress when
she left the company she brought with
her a trove of documents about private
facebook research she said that these
documents show that the company is aware
that its platforms amplify
misinformation hate and political unrest
that the company isn't doing enough to
change this and is hiding what it knows
ms haugen thank you for being with us
today um you
have said numerous times that uh these
documents point to facebook not doing
anything about its platforms promoting
um misinformation and hate could you
give us some examples of how this work
and what facebook isn't doing
i want to be clear it's not that
facebook isn't doing anything facebook
has pointed out they've invested
something like 16 billion i think that's
13 billion dollars since since 2016
on issues around safety and integrity
but the question is how much should they
be spending
is that is the amount of spending that
they have today enough and facebook's
documents are point to over and over
again that there are many many solutions
many of them not even content-based that
would make the platform safer for
everyone one of the core things that i'm
i'm trying to draw attention to is the
underinvestment in languages that aren't
english
they know that they face most regulatory
scrutiny in the united states and so
they try the hardest to keep the
platform nice in the u.s
unfortunately the most fragile places in
the world are also the most diverse when
it comes to languages
facebook's current strategy for safety
is that mark has said mark zuckerberg
has said engagement based ranking is
dangerous because people are drawn to
extreme content
but don't worry
ai will save us
the problem is that strategy requires us
to build those ai systems over and over
and over again in each language for the
platform to be safe and right now
facebook is not doing that
and um
so is it just a question of investment
and putting more money in there should
facebook change its algorithms what
should the company itself do
i'm a big proponent that you know if we
rolled back the clock and looked at what
facebook was like in 2008 2009 like
before we had an ai telling us what to
focus on we had a facebook that was
about our family and friends
facebook has said
we can't do time-based ranking you won't
like it yeah if you took the current
facebook today and switched it over to a
world where the ai wasn't focusing our
attention it's true you wouldn't like it
but if we redesign the platforms with
the idea that they should be human scale
not
mega scale with an ai focusing us around
those would be platforms that were about
our family and friends we could enjoy
them and they would be a lot safer
and you're now
in europe you're speaking to politicians
governments you're going to be speaking
at the european parliament
when it comes to reining in facebook
meta
and big tech
what do you expect from europe
i'm hoping that europe will stand up for
consumers because right now consumers
don't know if what's in the can is
what's on the label and what we see from
the disclosures that i've made is that
facebook is misconstruing what their
product is
the european union has an opportunity to
enforce transparency on the platforms in
a privacy sensitive way
and they have the ability to have
regulatory muscle to make facebook
disclose what our challenges it believes
exist with the platforms right now
people can't make informed choices on
whether or not to use these things and i
feel like that is that degrades our
autonomy because we don't have the
information to make good choices and
that violates our dignity
and um do you think the plans that for
example the european union is currently
working on do they go far enough
i'm a big proponent of what i call the
one two three plan so right now uh
facebook would have to articulate a risk
assessment
facebook is not very diverse
you know they largely centered in menlo
park california eight hours from europe
and eight hours from asia just to make
it hard to talk to them
i think there should have to be a second
step which is i'm a big proponent there
should be a singular a single regulator
for europe
and that regulator's job would not be so
much to tell facebook what to do but
would be to make sure that consumers had
the information they needed to make the
decisions so you can imagine that
regulator going out to civil society
groups and saying
what are the problems that you're seeing
so the combination of what facebook
knows and what those groups know can be
a shared list of challenges
and then the third part of the one two
three is facebook should actually have
to articulate what are they going to do
to solve each of those problems
because right now facebook just waves
their hands at us and says we're working
on it
and if facebook had to articulate those
harms in tandem with the community and
had to articulate what to solve how they
were going to solve them people would be
able to make informed choices on whether
or not to use these platforms and we've
seen facebook meta announced that it was
working on this metaverse an
all-encompassing future version of the
internet um how much does that worry you
i think the announcement around facebook
pivoting to video games illustrates a
meta problem for facebook which is that
over and over again facebook prioritizes
growth and expansion over making sure
that they've actually done a good job
with what they already have
i was shocked and frankly outraged when
facebook said that they could afford 10
000 engineers to build video games
because if we had had 10 000 engineers
to work on safety
we would have a profoundly different
platform one that i think all of us
would enjoy more
and do you think that this uh change of
name especially meta is something that
signifies a change within the company
and a pivot within the company
or is it a move that aims to clean up
maybe the company's image
i think it's a classic crisis playbook
that when you don't like the narrative
you change the narrative
i think facebook decided to rush out
this launch because they were hoping it
would distract us from the harms that i
articulated in my disclosure we need to
hold facebook accountable and say we
don't want you to put your sensors in
our homes we don't want you to spy on us
we don't want to have to expose
ourselves further until we trust that
you're going to do a good job because
you have consistently demonstrated that
you will lie to the public if it's in
your own best interests
how much responsibility does facebook
ceo mark zuckerberg have when we look at
um what you revealed and what we've been
seeing come out about facebook's
handling of the situation i really don't
like to criticize individuals because i
really think that this is a systemic
problem this is about incentives and
about structure uh structures leading to
bad consequences but in the end face
mark zuckerberg has 54 of all the voting
shares for facebook he is probably one
of the most powerful unilateral leaders
in the world
at the end of the day he is responsible
for the system he built and he has the
ability to change that system and so
given that he would rather shift the
conversation to video games when people
are dying as a result of the actions of
facebook i think that means that mark
mark needs to
either say no i need a reset we need to
change
or he needs to let someone else do that
we can say that in many places around
the world facebook is almost the
internet it's true how much of a danger
is is that
one of the things that i think has
should have us hold facebook to a higher
standard is that facebook bought the
privilege of being the internet for the
majority of languages in the world it
subsidized people's usage of the
platform of its own platform and said
hey you can use anything you want but
you have to pay for that or you can use
our platform for free as a result for
the majority of languages in the world
80 or 90 of all the content that exists
on the internet in those languages is on
facebook
i am deeply concerned about this because
as i said at the beginning the most
fragile places in the world are the most
linguistically diverse
and facebook has not demonstrated that
they are are willing to do the level of
care
and responsibility for those people that
is necessary
why was it so important for you to come
forward on this
i saw a pattern of behavior where i
believed
there was no chance the face would be
able to solve these problems in
isolation that there were too many
organizational pressures the incentives
were were misaligned
and i knew that if i didn't do something
and i saw what i feared was going to
happen continue to unfurl and like
ethiopia announced a state of crisis
yesterday because the situation there is
decayed so much
um
i knew i could never live with myself if
i watched you know 10 million 20 million
people over the next 20 years die
because of violence that was facilitated
by social media and so people often ask
me am i stressed right now like you're
talking to all these people like it's
such a whirlwind and compared to living
with that secret
like everything feels very calm right
now because i know
this is not a my problem anymore it's a
thing that we together can solve
you mentioned ethiopia you also tweeted
about it what role does social media and
facebook play in the situation
developing there right now
uh facebook has been tracking the
situation in ethiopia since q1 of 2020
right people have been talking about how
the escalating rhetoric on the on on
facebook around the dehumanization of
minorities in ethiopia has been a major
factor in the willingness to starve
certain parts of the population commit
violence against them
and this is one of these things where we
see over and over again
something that happens before ethnic
conflicts is usually the dehumanization
of people describing people like insects
when you have a platform that prioritize
prioritizes for distribution the most
incendiary content
you know even if a small minority is
describing some a group of people as
bugs
that that rhetoric is so much more
inflammatory and the platform
you know distributes it more um i worry
that ethiopia is just the opening
chapter in a novel that is too horrific
for us to want to read the end
and i think we all have an opportunity
especially here in europe to speak up
for those who don't have influence or
don't have a voice because europe is
strong enough to actually make a
difference
do you think users have already or are
developing awareness as to what
might be wrong with facebook what
happens with facebook and how important
is it for users to know
one of the reasons why i've been pushing
for this idea of you know we need risk
assessments that don't just involve a
company they also involve the community
is that people have been looking at
what's happening on facebook in
isolation they see maybe their own
experience of it
but they don't see the systemic problems
i think my disclosure has opened a crack
into
what the reality is on the on on this
platform
and i have been incredibly heartened by
the growing attention and the growing
awareness that we need to act
francis howard thank you very much
my pleasure anything to help